greetings from podcastville uncle joey's
joint is brought to you by
cbd lion listen when it comes to cbd
there's only one company i mess with and
that's cbdi and why
because it works and they have a great
selection
from the tinctures to the gummies
to the bath balls to the cbd infused
kinesiology tape
you can't beat this you cut a little
piece off put it on your shoulder your
knee your elbow
your eyebrow listen cbd line is the
company for me so do me a favor
go to cbdline.com right now press in
joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your [__] house
cbd
no liquor store no [__] the
joint is also brought to you by movement
watches this is one they sent me last
year
it still takes i love it it's tougher
than debt they're about to send me one
of the element international watches
and they're about to send me the dust
sunglasses in black
you guys know i have a problem driving
at night this is definitely going to
help me out listen
movement watches mbmt watches are all
about looking good while keeping it
simple
you don't have to tell me how many
[__] steps i've taken or
beep every time my lady texts me like a
true gentleman
it just tells you the time that's it get
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mbmt.com
joey again nbmt is launching new styles
on their site
all the time this is from last year but
i still love it check out their latest
mvmt.com selection so right now
go to dot com mvnt.com joey again
mbmt.com
joey join the movement
the joint is also brought to you by
manscape listen it's not about keeping
your balls trimmed
and your [__] fa you know your nut
sack and slinging dick
you can say a lot about things about me
i'm a criminal
i'm an immigrant i'm an old man but one
thing everybody knows about me my balls
are [__] beautiful
women wish their faces looked as tight
as my [__] ball skin
if you want beautiful women to fall all
over themselves for your big [__]
beat
beanbag you gotta get a manscape you
understand me
now they got the entire system to keep
your entire body looking as good as your
balls
ready for this they got the performance
package it comes with a weed whacker
nose trimmer which you [__] need how
else you're gonna take a cover test
if you got that bush growing in your
[__] nose god knows what's stuck in
that [__] bush
so now you get the lawnmower the crop
preserver the crap reviver
to keep everything smelling fresh which
they do
and trust me my balls stink so do me a
favor get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
joey again that's 20 off and free
shipping at manscape.com
joey clean your balls up [__] nice
welcome to uncle joey's joint
uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 21st of october
we're here for another fun-filled
episode of uncle joey's joint i hope you
guys are doing all right
i hope you're staying safe and i hope
you're doing all that [__]
i am feeling tip-top magoo thank you
for all the compliments you've been
sending me that i look a lot better let
me tell you something
i feel a lot better i had a uh
a heart doctor appointment my last
appointment with the doctor in la
and we did it on the phone and i had to
give them like my blood pressure reads
for what's going on
and because i usually take the blood
pressure in the morning and at night and
i
ju and i have to log it down everything
in my life is locked the [__] down guys
i got to write everything the [__] down
and i've been doing it for years but
we had like a little uh you know
interview on the
web zoom and he he was laughing because
i mentioned him on the rogue
podcast he said he never got so many
calls in one day to thank you and all
this [__] but
he asked me he goes you know i can't
give you any more collodipin
or your other medications i can't
prescribe more of a state you have to
get
some new [__] uh a new doctor which i
made an appointment yesterday to get my
a new primary and do a colonoscopy gotta
put that cam up your [__]
it's a [__] bad feeling you just go
down there they put you to sleep
they put a cam up your ass and they look
around but you got to do that
if not you know you're gonna find
problems later i'm way overdue i haven't
done one in like seven years
i'm thinking about redoing my knee in
december and since we're gonna be in
what's the [__] why am i gonna be out
there fist fighting for
and whatnot i'm thinking of a lot of
things but he asked me goes how are you
doing with the kalanapan and i go
i gotta tell you something i haven't
hate one in about eight days and he's
like what do you mean and i go
i just d you know like i d uh
got off those things i had him he would
give me prescriptions every three months
so i was just behind on him i never
really took him
unless i was going up on stage or
whatnot but once
[__] covert hit i was doing the
prescription which is for a [__] day
and then i cut off at six
and from six to [__] midnight i would
just sit there in a panic
attack and then i would have to start
eating edibles so he asked me because
can uh
you know how you've been doing like on i
still got
the you know a month supply maybe to one
supply
and he goes what happened to your
anxiety and i go i don't [__] know i
guess
i wrote it out i [__] you know
between the breeding the riding the bike
the writing the [__] patreon and just
doing what i'm supposed to do you know i
just uh
got rid of the fear what i basically did
was
all these people like hey man what are
you doing next week i'm just doing it
day to day
i have no [__] idea what i'm doing
next week i just go from day to day
by the way i added two more [__]
nights at uncle vinny's
november 18th and november 25th
uh so if you're in the area it's only 38
seats
don't [__] kill yourself over the
material
since last [__] wednesday i've been
writing little things down every day but
again
this week i'm gonna go in there a little
bit more open a little bit more loose
it's not carnegie hall you know it's
just 38 people
and i'm just [__] working out that's
why i kept the tickets
low because i'm just working out a lot
of people show up
you know so that's a good thing last
week gomez eleanor kerrigan
jimmy showed up you know this week we're
gonna have a nice house down there so
they have been fun but i'm not ready to
take like i have fears
but i don't have fears i'm cool around
my house and stuff
but i still look at my briefcase my
suitcase and i'm like
i'm not ready to pack that do i look at
my i sleep i look at my sleep apnea
machine and i'm like
i'm not ready to pack that either so for
right now i'm very cool
going to vinnies on wednesdays that
doesn't overstep my [__] boundaries
i think if i see a hundred people i have
a heart attack anyway
so for right now the fear in my everyday
life
is gone i still have little fears and
little things oh they might not be fears
i might just have [__] burnt out i
think i burnt out a little bit much on
the road
and i just want to pull it back for a
while that's that's what it could be
too so besides everything else i have no
fear my daughter is now
in school four days a week [__]
in california she would have been
looking at a wall right now
thinking about an episode of the
twilight zone but thank god we got the
[__] out of there because i
listen i don't know much about [__]
the
space or the moon or [__] politics or
the gop
or who's putting in a bill but i know
what a
little kid looks like when they're
[__] depressed i know what she was
going through so
now she's a [__] brand new kid and as
a father of your father
you see that as a blessing i mean she's
a bra whatever happened in l.a those
six months in the [__] house and the
swings being tied up and
people wouldn't talk to her people would
go up to it without a mask
you know those days are done with here
those days are done with
and i'm going to taste them the surges
all around the country right now
including [__] new jersey
there's hot spots popping back up it's
getting colder people are starting to
get comfortable
people are starting to let your guard
down listen guys don't let your [__]
guard down
you see what happened with rogan with
jamie jamie's got it
you know you're out there [__] around
and rogan's got a portable [__]
tester
that you could just go in there and test
everything so you can have all the
testing you want you can have all the
stuff you want
you never know when you're gonna bump
into it so please
stay cautious of this [__] i don't wanna
i don't wanna picture you from [__]
facetime with vows in your nose
telling me joey this is my last week
make me a video i
i can't have that i can't have that
that's why i have not had guests on yet
you know i never liked [__] zoom i
just don't like [__] zoom
if we gotta do it we'll do it but
i'm not [__] too crazy about it right
now i have a couple people have
contacted me
to maybe zoom in i'll start doing a
couple of those pretty soon
but right now i'm just finding my voice
on here this is the beginning of uncle
joey's joint i'm just trying to find a
[__] voice
i'm not trying to [__] knock it out
of the park or whatever
yes i had a co-host and i still have a
[__] co-host
you don't want to say nothing that's
fine with me you know what i'm saying
uh we're just here we're just existing
and we're pushing it through i want to
thank you people who have joined
the patreon and have gone through levels
and whatnot
because i tell you what man have that
money i pay taxes on
i'm gonna end up paying taxes on but the
other half of that money i helped
i have helped some people having a hard
time you know
you know we got mike we got last time
my men made me music for free for the
podcast and i took it from
this time i knew you know everybody's
having a hard time
i called them up i said what do you want
for the music whatever
we donated to the mark weiss museum
every wednesday i hire one of my nephews
or a friend who i think is struggling
and i haven't give me a ride to uncle
vinnie's and i pay him as a driver
so i want you guys to know that you're
helping a lot of [__] people here
patreon the same way i helped you guys
for free on youtube i didn't give a [__]
i got up at six in the morning that was
my duty i'm not rogan i'm not bill burr
i gotta work for your [__] love i
gotta work for it
you know i just didn't you know i'm not
chappelle i'm not that lucky
never wanted to be them i wanted to be
joey diaz
so joey diaz turned a little different i
looked i did a little different i had to
attack you guys from a different [__]
perspective
to let you know i'm not just on why i
could do it don't get me wrong
i'm [__] out of my bird but i ain't
no [__] whacking through here i just
uh i have a heart like everybody else
and i'm human
and i uh want to say what the [__] is on
my mind like i said last week
so if you got me on patreon you guys are
doing a great job
i thank you with all my [__] heart
whether it's a dollar well we
raised the three five 10
15 whatever you guys are helping on a
lot of people
and i thank you for that from the bottom
of my heart because i know how i [__]
feel i know the look on their faces
you know when i and i tell them listen
i'll do this for you i i i could feel it
and it makes me feel good that i'm
helping people during such a [__]
horrible time
you know when i crack jokes about
unemployment and i crack those jokes i'm
not
us insulting anybody i told you guys
back in march to stop [__] around
the unemployment was going to be a
[__] nightmare the ppe loans people
are still waiting for them
this government is holding on to them
listen just just
just find a different way i'd rather you
find a different way
and struggle for a month then struggle
for six or seven months
waiting for a check that might or might
not [__] come correct
i'd rather you jump on the path listen i
was a [__] mess
until i started this podcast going up
again until i started getting back on
stage
because i got back to the movements i
was doing you know i didn't know
how much of a big change it had been on
my psyche
that i wasn't able to do [__]
stand-up comedy it's
you cannot imagine me just cutting your
[__] legs off here if you're an i.t
guy you could work from the house but if
you're a [__] attorney right now
you could do work from the house but
your work is on a [__] courtroom
my work is on a [__] stage you know
yeah i could do a podcast and i could do
other things but let's figure this all
out
for the last 39 years my work has been
on the stage
so i cut my la i got my legs cut off
just like you guys
we had to do ulterior methods you know i
wanted to [__]
have a bar for a [__] podcast the bar
is still there
we couldn't get everything in time mac
books are out covered won't deliver the
share the wiring
the electrician took four [__] weeks
you know kovitz putting a toll on
everything
it's like i got a designer also and then
i paid him
instead of giving you that same [__]
jesus with the machine gun
that my wife made with some [__]
thing we got a graphic designer for you
we paid him on just to help you guys you
guys saw the design on patreon
for the tr uh for the uncle joey's joint
and we got more church things coming but
again
it's the [__] coping that's slowing
everything the [__] down
my patches were made in hong kong i
think like two doors down from hunan
from who won so whatever the [__] so if
you bought a [__] patch
don't don't sniff it because it might
have covered on it god knows it came
from china
after [__] you [__] are getting
we're getting from [__] covet
so uh getting from china i'm sorry i
don't mean to call china kobe though
i'm sounding like [__] trump i'm just
[__] saying that
you know half the [__] we got was from
china and now we're realizing i don't
have a generator coming to [__]
february
and i got a storm lurking outside the
[__] pacific whatever so
you know everybody's behind on
everything
so when you hit if you're on patreon and
you hit me for the shirts
i don't have an idea i don't have any
[__] they're still sending the
samples over
i'm gonna hopefully get the samples for
you guys long sleeve hoodies
this week i'm gonna look at the three
different materials they give me whether
it's gildan
whatever the fun i'm gonna get you the
best possible shirt i can
it's gonna be a long sleeve you get that
with you
and then if you want to buy hoodies for
the mind of
or hoodies for the joint all this [__]
will be available
in time right now we're all waiting i
think my wife reached out to a [__]
thing
and they had tons of extra large
tons of excel uh two and three and four
fat people would had a party that would
have been curtains for years
but they had no mediums and no largest
so
we're just getting thrown into that
[__] thing so work with me
you know i'm a solid [__] you
will get your [__] t-shirt
you will get your [__] merch but just
work with me because
everything is [__] slow right now the
only thing i can promise you i can give
you
is this something happens we could
always give you this we could always put
a [__] video on youtube just to keep
you together
keep your [__] sound and keep you
happy that's what i'm trying to do
it's just keep you guys happy and keep
you motivated on all the living is for
the day
just for the day people hey what are you
doing saturday i have no
[__] idea i know what i'm doing this
saturday i got the double combo from
death
i got khabib gaijin and the honeymoon is
archie bunker
i'm not going nowhere [__] saturday
night
that is the fight of the [__] year
who's gonna win
i have no idea i have not seen the
[__] weigh-ins
you know if i'm not doing nothing
saturday night or i may
don't make plans maybe we'll do a little
live stream just of khabib
and gaiji right off the phone just to
[__] with you [__]
i have no [__] idea what i'm doing
sadly i don't know what i'm doing
[__] friday
all i know is i gotta get a p.o box and
i gotta get a haircut this [__] week
something's gotta [__] give
that's all i [__] know i don't know
nothing else i don't know nothing people
are you
are you coming to this restaurant i
don't know nothing
tonight i go to vinnie's that's all i
[__] know i don't know nothing i got
a kid that [__] gets home at 12 30
and from there on i got nothing for you
so if you bother me you [__] call me
i don't [__] know what to tell you i
got a kid that comes home at 12 30 and
then she goes back on the zoom
from two to three thank god that's
[__] over no more [__] zoom for
the kids
so now she gets home at three thursdays
she starts going to the little after
school program and that gives me a
little bit more time
but pretty much i'm living day to day
these [__] agents calling me
i did you want to go to pittsburgh i
don't want to go nowhere
i don't want to go [__] nowhere you
just keep calling and keep asking and
keep getting office you knock yourself
out i'll tell you whatever the [__] you
want to hear
i'll tell anybody whatever the [__] they
want to hear but in my world right now i
always live like this
i always live day to day why the [__]
are you doing
you know what am i gonna do three years
from now i don't know the other day my
wife came down
oh my god my brother's gonna lose his
job in five years
in five years he'll figure something to
[__] out but right now you got to work
with what's in front of you i'm
more concerned about my daughter i'm
concerned about my family
i'm worried about you guys i mean you
guys have been family with me well for
10 years now we've been [__] going
back and forth
that's my concerns when you guys send me
emails you know i
get little [__] emails i read them
all you know i read them all
and i see what's going on with you and i
can't really [__] you know i got too
many
[__] that i'm dealing with but
one thing for sure my heart goes out to
basharos
i love you that uh my man jay contacted
me yesterday
and uh they found something and he's
gonna be fine
you know when i first read it i was a
little upset i liked the macheros out of
[__] pittsburgh
but the problem was i know he's going to
be fine i couldn't let him know
how upset i was because there's really
nothing to be upset right now if you got
cancer i have a friend
that's been free basin coke he's been
rubbing coke in his eyeballs
this kid's been on drugs since we were
sophomores together we did
coke the first day together he just got
cancer
and he went for five treatments and they
were gone
and this guy is in no condition to do
anything he understand me he's got coke
pete he's got the whole thing
so if he could beat it you guys can be i
have faith in god
and i have faith in the science and
medicine today it's like if you get cold
but listen
it's not the end of the world the flu
kills more people
i just don't want you to go through that
i don't like hospitals
it's not so much i'm scared to call oh
it's cold with each other
no that's what the media wants you to do
to be [__] petrified to drop
everything you got and to instill
fear into your life have you seen that
[__] video
or that thing by paul harvey if i was
the devil
have you guys ever saw seen that [__]
video if i was a devil
he [__] made this in like 1950. paul
harvey was a is a guy that
does a one-hour radio show i don't know
if he still does it today or not
i discovered paul harvey in 1983
in uh snowman's village colorado when i
was working that was odd carrier
and people would listen to poor
heartbeat that one hour
whatever the [__] paul harvey got to say
he's got to say
and he did this thing maybe 1951 i think
you have to look it up
and it's like uh like a like a podcast
15 minute thing
where he says if i was the devil and he
starts with this
long [__] sentence about what he
would do if he would be the devil
and half of it is what's going on with
this covert right now
i mean if you think about what's going
on right now you've all years have lost
a relative during this through this
whether the covert or not to covet i've
lost
maybe four people throughout this whole
thing
two of them since i've been in jersey
which is two months
um so i've been losing one person a
month that's under [__] 60. so
it's just going around guys the world is
turned up on attacks
access nobody knows what's going on and
we're not here to figure it out
we're just here to plow [__] through
it
i don't want you sitting there [__]
being you know
i wonder what the [__] has going on no
nothing nothing that we know about on
this [__] nothing
it's a corona virus it came from here we
don't really even know
i don't believe that guys i don't
believe dick anymore
i wear my mask they tell me if i need to
go into a business
i need to wear a mask i wear my mask if
i see a circle of people
i slip my mask up i don't get myself
into cavorio [__] situations you know
i love to be able to go
do a show for 250 people but me
knowing me who i am and joe diaz and one
of those 250 people
gets sick because of me i'm not gonna
feel too good
that's not what i do i'm not gonna feel
too good so before we do that
38 people in a room that seats 180
doesn't scare the [__] out of me i think
uncle vinnie's just doing a [__]
great job they're sticking to it
it's these [__] galvon greedy
[__]
that playing russian roulette with
people's lives i won't tolerate
i just won't tolerate it you don't need
to [__] see you know what i have a
great time every night
i sit down i put a different album on i
smoke a joint
whatever the [__] i do and i listen to
what i'm and i'm just as enjoyed
as if i go to a [__] concert you see
guns and roses trying to sell tickets
you see all the top bands trying to sell
tickets they're not
because they don't they know they don't
need the aggravation the insurance
but what they don't need is their
[__] anything on their conscience
i don't want to invite anybody on huh a
comedy show and you go back to your
grandmother she punches the ticket
and there's no thanksgiving because some
stupid joke uncle jerry was going to
[__] say
it's not worth it to me and it's not
worth it to you guys for 38 people
i'm fine you know everybody around me is
like don't you want to do that down
there
they see 80. listen two more weeks you
can't do no shows outside
you're gonna be a [__] penguin these
animals are gonna get hungry
they're gonna come out early i'm not
doing those shows outside
i love it don't get me wrong if this is
still the way it is
next year at this time i'm doing an
outdoor [__] tour
if i'm ready if they allow it i don't
you know the numbers gotta be kept small
because it's those big [__] super
spreader events
and i don't want to be a part of those
that's it and that's that
i miss you guys more than you miss me
live you don't think i i miss going
on stage and tearing it the [__] up i
[__] miss it
but right now i'm not in the condition
the country's not in the condition
so for right now we'll just sit back
look at each other we'll do the podcast
if you want to [__] around you come on
patreon you can ask me a message on
twitter
facebook i'm around but for right now
that's all we got
tip top magoo we're going to keep this
going so i because i want all these
healthy
2021 is gonna be a great year listen
is in the books already
you got to assume if you're still
thinking
uh i have a date december 18th with my
band
and canipsy but listen get rid of that
idea
that's not gonna happen you and your
[__] band you know get to the garage
put masks on and get the [__]
rehearse in those [__] songs
right now a band is writing right now a
band is putting melodies together right
now
a rap is putting beats together you're
in your house
what else did you do what else do you
want to do nothing you could do you want
to invite 20 people for your house and
then have a crime stopper across the
street call and say you're doing
functions at your house pasadena lena
i just avoid all that [__] i keep it to
myself saturday night is a fight
i like to watch it here but i just moved
to the area i would also love to go to a
bar
maybe sit outside maybe watch the fights
but i know at eight o'clock i'm gonna
freeze to that i don't want to be inside
a place with a [__] mask and i'm not
being able to drink or eat
so i might as well get the fight watch
it at home
combine it with the honeymooners my
regular so i'm gonna have a great
[__] saturday night oh
and if you see i'm not talking about
food i'm trying to
cut my weight down i'm trying to keep it
down i'm just talking about
entertainment
i'm trying to entertain myself what i am
doing in other words is
i'm trying to live a life so i have
material for you
i ran out of material i've already told
you all about my [__] life for the
last [__]
56 years it's time to do some new
adventures
i went to museums i've been to record
shops i've been
laughing i've been giggling i've been
keeping it to a [__]
you know if i don't have to go but i
also believe in my sanity
the same way i believe in my daughter
sandy that you have to talk with certain
people to keep up you have to rap i
believe in that too
so every day i meet with somebody a
neighbor i got my man frankie down the
corner
i got my man rudy up the corner i got
steve around the corner with his wife
they're all cool people
i take my bike and i ride and guess what
i call for them
a 57 year old man ringing your doorbell
going hey
i'm not here for your kids i want to see
what you're doing and they freak out
i do it to all of them i ring in that
doorbell they come out
we [__] talk [__] i haven't unleashed
a reefer on them because i don't want to
scare them you know what i'm saying
i'm trying to make friends so i don't
want to give somebody a 200 milligram
edible
and they end up in mount sinai and then
i'm like that [__] jew that went
skiing and new rochelle and came back
and infested the whole [__]
neighborhood now people are throwing
eggs on them and it's not even halloween
you know how many eggs they've thrown at
that [__] jew's house up in new
rochelle
he's gotten eggs thrown out of his house
[__] every day since he [__]
spread [__] the cope into the
community
i wonder where the [__] that
[__] is now
that if i was him i would move to
[__] bulgaria
that's like making a bad [__] movie
and then going out the next day and
people like oh
we saw your movie uh we gotta go
and they get in the [__] car it's the
same thing if you spray cobra in the
neighborhood you ain't gonna be like too
much
it's the same thing with me i gotta
start out like when i go out this last
party i went to last week it was a
little like
outside cookout in the daytime they had
a big screen tv
i'm not gonna lie to you i showed up
with a bag of 20 milligram metals
at the end of the night i mentioned it
and some people said ah let me try you
know and i just
so right now i can't be killing people
yeah that lifestyle
you know i can't pull an arian bird out
here it just
it just would crash who the [__] i'm
trying to be out of here i'm trying to
be a responsible parent
so i haven't i haven't even showed up
with the abx or whatever the [__] they
are the atx abx edibles
those little 200 milligrams will [__]
bury them i haven't done one in like two
weeks either
i listen i had to give those abx's
they're just
too [__] strong if you're in the mood
to really see the [__] devil
see now that i don't do it every day i
see what's true
i'm sitting here going wow what the [__]
was i thinking eating three of those
where the [__] was my head at that day
i can't i can't no i'm on a light
schedule now i got these little [__]
protabs
i gave my man mike a couple the other
day
and hey you got to worry about because i
actually think pro tabs put something in
that stuff
because you get thc high but you like
this other high like you're scratching
your neck type of heroin high like
something ain't [__] right
so there's something else in those pro
taps i could take like two or three of
them just to keep the blood going it's
only 75 milligrams
but once i [__] with over four of those
things no bueno no bueno i start [__]
speaking low
no bueno my wife called me out last week
[__]
lee said something to me because you
sounded [__] last wednesday after i
bombed
i needed something to bring down the
pain you know saying sometimes when you
bomb you can take it
and sometimes you can't i took it don't
get me wrong
but at the same time it hurt my [__]
feelings a little bit why is it
that every time i want to do a podcast
the mexican shows up with the weed
whacking machine you understand me
no [__] every time this [__] every
time i do a [__]
podcast this [__] mexican shows up on
a [__] tuesday morning why is that
it's either the the mexican dude or my
delta is jumping up upstairs i can't win
but that's what happens
by not having an office but again this
is just the beginning
guys this is just the beginning of this
evolution
if you know anything about me we grow we
grow we add we grow
we add it's just doing it to find my
voice until i find my voice
when we started we had different
pictures up i had the picture of joe
rogan
i saw [__] the evil that men do i'm
like what am i thinking where's charles
bronson on my way i'll let these people
know
i'm not from the [__] uh fabulous
four
or you know the wrestling i came from
[__] killers that's why i came from
clint eastwood
charles bronson and [__] the other
[__] james coburn
those were my people these new movies oh
the rock i'm not impressed i love the
rock i got another guest to rock i watch
all his [__] movies
i watch jumanji with my daughter i love
the rug but
i came from a different i didn't come
from the rock i came from charles
bronton with wrinkles and a gun
you know what i'm saying nobody was
doing steroids that day they showed up
with wrinkles and a [__] gun
that's where i'm from all right so i
don't know nothing about the rock but
none of these [__] sidewalk fair
[__] actors today i like them
i like them but they're not the guys i
grew up with i grew up on
[__] savages bronson coburn mcqueen
you know clint eastwood these guys if
you know anything about their personal
lives
they were smacking people gorilla
punching people
[__] clint eastwood pissed on a
director's grave when the guy died with
steve mcqueen steve mcqueen
these guys were from a different cut
they're from the cut i come from
you know you're gonna treat me like a
man i'm gonna act like a [__] man and
you're gonna act like a man
these other people you know these are
like sad warfare type actors you know
they care about [__] you can look
through youtube
charles bronson didn't care about nobody
guy never did a [__] psa in his life
he didn't care about missing kids
he didn't care about hemophiliacs he
didn't give two [__] [__] about
nobody
these guys do it to make you [__]
like them the guys i grew up with did
what they did
and either you like them or you [__]
don't
you know the big difference of what my
daughter here in california is this is
the difference
and i didn't know this till i observed
and this is what i was looking for this
is the result i was looking for
like you tell people you know what man i
really don't think california
was made for kids but you'll say like
joey you got disneyland you got
knottsbury farm you got all these
[__] attractions for kids
they're there to entertain kids they
don't teach kids
how to entertain themselves that's what
that's what's been missing in society
lately you know i'm going to talk about
this bit
in front of you guys it's a bit that i'm
working on
but it's also the truth i've been here
for two months and i've been watching
these kids in the neighborhood
great kids great kids luke florentine
great kid his friends great kids they're
[__] savages you know
not in my block but jimmy florentino
lives close to me his block is called a
little rascals block
because they got kids from five all the
way to like 12.
they all play together they have a
little hill
yesterday my daughter went on that hill
dog she did that [__] scooter
if she didn't go back and forth on that
scooter 20 times
she didn't go back and forth you know
those [__] dudes who walk with that
one leg but they walk slow with that one
[__] up wooden leg
if my daughter has a one leg that [__]
is gonna [__] move with it you should
have seen her and the other little girl
and those little boys
they pushed that scooter with that one
leg that one leg's gonna be bigger than
the other they don't give a [__] they're
going up and down
i talked to the florentine last night
we're gonna go what's going on over
there goes
luke is passed down [__] my daughter's
still awake but she told me at dinner
time she's like dad
i went up and down that hill 20 times
like i saw it
and one time i saw her run up kids are
taught here how to entertain themselves
and wait till the snow comes out that
was the difference between california
they were there to entertain you you had
to pay 144 to go to disneyland
and walk three hours in the sun and pay
seven dollars for a water
to get entertained i didn't want to do
that anymore i wanted my daughter to
learn how to entertain herself
the same way i entertained myself the
point i was getting that
you know i watched these kids play and
they're great and i love them even the
kids on my blog
are [__] great they they got bikes my
daughter like today my daughter plays on
the block
today because the other boys do all this
[__] today so there's only one girl on
jimmy's block
but today they get serious the guys they
don't want the little girls out
so today she stays in this neighborhood
here what the [__] was i gonna tell you
i know he's gonna tell you something
but i [__] forgot you see what
happens when you smoke weed over the
years
ah
it's just a little bit left so who knows
in an hour my eyeballs would be [__]
purple
whatever the [__] i don't even know what
i was talking about i was talking about
my kids and [__]
let me drink some water here to remind
me
when we went out as kids like like i see
my daughter
[Music]
and she looks at playing as going out to
play and i'm really happy
i'm really happy that she has these
little friends and that
we get invited to social distance
[__] barbecues and all this [__]
these people are doing it right
but there's a difference between the
generation now the youngest generation
and i spoke to a friend of mine
yesterday just to double check
and he's going to call me back today
because he was like you're not wrong
but i don't i don't see it that way i go
who else would have done these things
when kids go out today to play
they go out to play when we went out as
kids
we went out to die like you hugged your
mother really [__] good like
we're not gonna make it back mom you
know i know you guys saw that
documentary on action park
you know again i only went up there one
time but
they went there for you to die like i
don't know how many kids broke necks
there and ankles
and it was well [__] hidden they
didn't give a [__] and
the kids would probably tell you you
know what i'm not gonna sue the place
because i had a good time while i was
doing i want that to die
you know all you kids said at 19. i feel
suicidal yeah that's because
you were 15 you didn't play to die when
we went you know we threw snowballs on
each other with a rock and it froze
we'd dip it in water that's six [__]
stitches right off the [__] back you
know
i didn't know nothing about playing
[__] monopoly you think i play
monopoly guys
i'm embarrassed i play monopoly before
the [__] hotels and i'm bored that's
it we gotta get out
we're sitting in a basement playing
[__] monopoly buying hotels with am i
[__]
the guy from virgin i don't need this
[__] flying around
i'm a kid i want to go out and [__]
throw records and rocks of people
and get chased by people i played the
[__] and die
we threw [__] you know heard my stories
we had mr martinez that guy would kill
people
i would throw things at him i would
throw things in this [__] i would like
pieces of paper on fire and throw them
in this [__] basement
since i'm six i'm playing to [__] die
i wasn't playing the [__] and have a
good time huh
you want to have a good time get
yourself a [__] pet chihuahua and a
hat with a propeller
and you know do what you do but i'm not
looking for a good time like that i'm
looking for a good [__] time
it's when i get up on stage i don't go
up on stage to [__] die
and that's what happened last wednesday
my energy just wasn't there
i went up there like talking to him like
i'm talking to you here this ain't no
[__] chick chat
i got to be an animal up on stage i
don't go up on stage
well something funny happened to me
today nothing [__] funny happened
we're going at it today let me tell you
what [__] happened today
and that's what i was missing from my
set last week too i didn't have that
[__] anger
i was too relaxed i was too uh
you know i gotta be worked up to go on
stage i gotta be angry at something i
gotta find something to be
when i was in the sixth grade that
[__] buried borrowed my coleman
didn't give it back to me i gotta get
pissed about [__] like that you don't
get pissed about something
that ain't got nothing to do with the
price of eggs
that's me i know that's why when i drive
to a gig
i like peace this week i'm the reason
why i have a driver is to help people
out like i told on patreon
and to just be personal with somebody
for a night these are my nephews they're
young
they've heard things you know they don't
really get to know me
so uh i call them up i say take me down
i give them a surprise at the end of the
night they're like i didn't really need
that but it doesn't matter to me
it doesn't matter to me i just want to
make somebody's day i don't have that
much time anymore
that you know because of this [__]
colvin
you don't get a chance to make people's
day no more
yeah i could call you know i checked him
with dio i checked him with
joe i checked him with the boys but like
i always preach to you guys you got to
make somebody's day
it's tough when you don't see nobody it
makes somebody's day you could call them
and
giggle you know i've given cbd
products to neighbors around my house
like i said i have been the perfect
neighbor so far because
this isn't california no more the people
that had his neighbors in california
except for susie and ron next to me were
total [__] pukes
i lived in a puke neighborhood i had gay
bob up the corner but nobody liked him
because he was [__] gay you know you
know
in california to live for gay people but
the real
crazy gay guy on my block nobody really
liked this he was a little bit too
crazy you know what's either you like
gay people you know i don't care how
they come
that's why when you lgbt people complain
about me and crack a joke you know
you're wrong because i love you
[__]
and the crazier you are the more
flamboyant
the more i love you if i saw a gay guy
walking down the street with his dick
out
i would take a picture that [__]
put on twitter and laugh my ass off
i love all that [__] the gay people i
hate are the uptight gay people
that think that they got something over
you they think they're special for being
gay now i got no time for you the gay
friends i have a buck wild
if they get a [__] venereal disease
they just move on you know what i'm
saying
they don't call nobody they don't send
the memo they're out busting [__]
and [__] giving
out [__] sandwiches they don't give a
[__] anybody read that
rob alpha book yet oh my god
oh my [__] god i was talking to jimmy
about one of the chapters
where rob halford i guess goes to
chicago every year
and every year when he lands for the
tour he a guy cuts his hair
and the guy kept busting his balls a
little bit every year like hey
you know how people like sexually come
on d like hey so
are you gonna give me a go i guess after
like a couple years of hearing this [__]
rob hoffman said you want me to go home
with you i'll go home with you
he [__] him so hard he broke his
o-ring
the guy had to sit in the hospital for a
week with a busted [__]
that's what i wanted to read that's
what's interesting
that's the [__] they never put in people
magazine you understand me
for years all we ever heard was that
richard gere put a mouse in his ass
and went to [__] they've been telling
you the same lie
for 30 years about richard gere my man
that poor buddhist
then he put a mouse up his ass and he
had to go to the emergency room in san
francisco and take it out that's what
i've been living on for 20 years finally
a new gay guy comes out with a whole new
story that he
busted somebody's [__] [__] and he
put him in the hospital for a week
that's a [__] story right there not
something i like to do
not something i like to mimic i'm not in
business to bust people's [__]
that's not what i'm into
i think i've done anal one time i didn't
like it because
she was laying there like tapping out
like don't do it it's too much drama
just stick it in your monkey
and let's get this party over with i
gotta put vaseline on my dick or some
type of lube but sticking in your ass
with a condom
and then you're all jiggly you're
squirming that's not comfortable that's
not sex
those porno girls i don't know how they
put a dick in their ass the guy's
banging them and they're smiling
and then their [__] stays open for a
[__] hour i don't know how they do
that [__]
i don't want to be involved that [__]
that's never been my game i'm a catholic
i don't want to [__] nobody empty ass
and i'm saying
if these [__] priests want to [__]
people that's their business
i come from a different side of the
[__] catholic uh
spectrum it was weird i had to talk with
somebody that day
and they recommended a book to me
and this is the craziest thing i've ever
heard i don't even know who recommended
this to me
but in these days and times people come
up with the weirdest [__] [__]
somebody was talking to me about that
there's either a book
or an article or something out
about the apostles that instead of
drinking wine
they were really drinking
like a mushroom juice
and that everything that happened with
jesus
they just saw in their trip
interesting interesting i could see that
[__] happen
because i've eaten some edibles i've
said i've been in some situations i've
seen people do some crazy [__]
from breathing fire to people's eyes
spinning out around their [__] head
i've been there but to [__]
be through a a mushroom trip
or something that experiences seeing a
guy get beat up
crucified put in a hole and then
floating away
if that exists can you please let me
have some
because that's just too heavy
i could see if you ate a mushroom and
saw jesus get beat up
that then i'm in with you but now you're
telling me that the reason you saw jesus
turn [__] bread into fish
and turn water into wine is because
you're on mushrooms
it's the craziest thing i've ever heard
in my [__] life
unless they were on windowpane acid for
a [__] two years
i don't know how that could have [__]
existed i have no [__] idea
but if that's what you want to believe
that's who you want to believe like i
could say
i could see one day going yeah i ate
mushrooms and i saw jesus fly off into
the [__] clouds
i could live with that one but as far as
that whole
experience him getting beat up mary
magdalene wiping his face
him being in the cave getting dragged
you know getting stabbed getting [__]
nails put in his hands
that's some [__] serious acid right
there to live through all that
those are three days alone i don't know
about you guys
you eat three days of [__]
hallucinogenics just friday saturday and
sunday
you'll be bleeding [__] from monday to
[__] friday i don't know how they
[__]
made it to easter to see how the [__]
jesus came
i don't even know why we're talking
about this conversation but this is the
[__] people talk to me about
and i want to bring it to the table if
anybody else has heard about it
please give me a message if they can
simplify this for me
because i'm [__] confused i have to
keep it simple
you know i put up two articles last week
just to justify my existence
i put up the cuban the cuban superman uh
the superman of cuba
and it broke it down for you people you
know i wasn't [__] eating an edible
and made it up you know the story i told
on the cabin with bert
and the other story is the one i talked
about on
uh my my boys show the honeydew podcast
i talked about that guy
uh you know i did time with that always
showed me
naked pictures of his girlfriend and she
was hot and i'm like
you're working over your head this is
not gonna work out for you
and then the [__] was so good guys he
escaped from jail
he was in a different jail that i was in
i went to camp george west
they put him in some medium security
jail and this knucklehead when his
girlfriend left him escaped from jail
broke out drove for a [__] hour stole
a car
from canyon city drove up to boulder
he went on to a [__] he went to lee
hill road or on upstate of leho road
one of the many roads behind [__]
boulder he saw four kids shooting
practice target and he went up to him
with like a fake [__] badge or
whatever he said
he said guys this isn't uh land
for you to be shooting on you got to put
your guns down on the floor real quick
while i inspect you or whatever the kids
put the guns down
he gathered all the guns up he made the
kids turn around
then he shot him execution style i put
that [__] story out there people like
that never happened thank god
one [__] guy one [__] guy
actually came up with the article and i
put it up
and people were like joey what the [__]
life have you lived i'm trying to tell
you i'm not here [__] around i've
bumped into the best people in the world
and i have bumped into the worst people
in the [__] world the best
and the worst all at once that was a
horrible [__] night in boulder my
daughter at that time not mercy the one
that don't talk to me
had to be a year old
so it had to be 91
it was warm out it was very nice out we
were selling cars and all of a sudden
[__] cops were all over the place
and i remember that they sent us home
from boulder toyota that's why i worked
at the place
i was a salesman at bowl deteriorated
for a guy named jim handy
who i still speak to by the way and he
was mike he was the guy that turned me
on to goals and doing all that [__] we
just spoke about two weeks ago
my heart goes out to jimin he's a good
man and i left him over there in pismo
beach by himself but i love him to death
i love his kids
but i remember with me jim andy and the
[__] they
kind of closed the dealership because
the guy was on the loose
nobody knew what the [__] he was and
then he was spotted at kmart which was
the same kmart
i called the cops from when they were
looking for me in boulder do you
remember that story when i told you i
was in front of kmart
calling the cops and they were going
into albertsons i was in front of that
kmart
that came out was across the street from
where i lived so supposedly after he
shot the four kids
he went into the k-mod and bought more
ammunition
and then the cops went over there so
there was cops all over my [__] house
me i always got a piece and i was a
scared of the guy i knew the guy was
crazy over [__] he was gonna shoot me
but
i went home i got my guns ready and i
think that night i actually had a little
bit of
powder and my wife was upstairs asleep
and i went in the back room even though
i was in the halfway house
and i did a couple bumps i got no reason
to lie to you guys you guys know about
my drug crazy path
and the next morning they shot him
maybe three quarters of a mile down from
the kmart
there was a little jazz bar that they
knocked down way before i left boulder
in 95
i think that's why they knocked it down
because they shot the guy
in front of that well-known jazz bar and
they felt like their reputation was
ruined or whatever
but yeah they shot him in the [__]
neck and
when they went to surgery that night the
guy that shot the four kids that the
cops were looking for
the only that's what they didn't tell
you in that story
the only person that could operate him
that was qualified
was one of the kids fathers that he had
shot
so he shot a kid and one of their
fathers
was a surgeon that could have saved them
and he declined to save
that's what they didn't say in that
story and that's what
came the days afterward that they were
thinking of charging the father
because he took an oath and all that
[__] so it's pretty interesting [__]
so that's why i posted those two
articles just so you guys could see that
[__] the [__] about jesus eating
mushrooms
you know i i listen
i was really raised catholic i was
really raised to believe
and after everything i've been through
in my life i do believe there's
something
out there you know what i'm saying but i
don't believe
that the apostles ate a [__] mushroom
trip for a [__] month and a half
while jesus was doing all these [__]
magic tricks and that they saw that
under mushroom conditions i'm not going
to accept that as a catholic
that's [__] blasphemy where i come
from and that's it and that's that i
don't know if you guys noticed
that the [__] director of the
exorcist
retweeted me and joe rogan doing a
[__] thing on him
and i've never been so happy in my life
his name is
william freaking he was the director of
the exorcist
and he was the director of the french
connection this guy was a bad
[__]
and about two weeks ago i got a call
from a friend of mine john salami
that he goes you're not gonna believe it
[__] william freaking just retweeted
you and rogan cause i was
giving rogue on here beat about what i
think is the exorcist you guys have
heard they have beaten before about
me telling you the exodus is one of the
greatest stories of all time
he [__] retweeted it and i hit him
back with a thank you and they hit me
back with a thank you so
my week is [__] good last week i
forgot to tell you that [__]
[__]
what do you think you're dealing with
jerry bananas and [__] you like the
little [__] sweater with the
international on it don't you
look at the handsome clan there's an old
[__] sweater my wife can never shrink
it this is when i was like 418 pounds
i just wore it it's starting to get a
little nip in the air and i'm going to
look good for you people i don't want to
be wearing no [__] t-shirts like i'm
20 years old
i'm a 57 year old grown man for [__]
christ's sakes
but i don't know what else to talk to
you [__] about
all i know is it's been great my two
months here
i'm happy i made the move i'm happy you
[__]
supported me you know i still get
questions
like last night one of my dear friends
called me i know this guy since the six
[__] grade and this is what he asked
me last night about 11 o'clock
i'm trying to watch the [__] news or
something i don't know what i was
watching last night
i was like oh i was trying to watch that
uh two nights ago i was watching that
horrible dallas football game
oh my god the dallas cowboys gotta get
it together i mean listen
it said i know it's a covered season
but that's america's team they looked
horribly at night
and i just put them on for a minute
because one of my friends went to the
game in dallas
and he's a big dallas fan so i was i was
going through a tv and i saw that i was
playing
and i'm like what the [__] is this
in the middle right before i could get
[__] upset a friend of mine called me
that i've known since the sixth grade
and he's telling me that you know thank
you for calling him
when i got here that he's been busy with
work blah blah blah
but then he dropped something on me that
was just [__] insane he asked me
he was telling me the truth i've known
you a long time
why did you really move here
and i go what are you talking about i
told you
before i even left i called him to tell
him i was moving back and i'd see him
he goes did you leave a warrant did you
do something did you beat somebody up
and i go no
why is that what you thought you know
everybody has their own
thing while i left out like i left that
light just because it was over
i don't have to tell you i mean i didn't
even i felt so
happy when i didn't repeat this it's not
you know like when you have a guy and he
goes through a bad relationship with a
girl
and after they break up he badmost the
girl i'm not here to badmouth california
california was very good to me i had a
great time in california i wouldn't
stayed out there for 23 years
it became something else and after i
came here i caught myself a couple times
talking about california in a negative
way and i'm like you know what
i'm not going to say that [__] no more
if somebody brings it up to me
i got no problem with it the other day i
went to the park
to watch a football a basketball game
jimmy's kid was playing basketball and
somebody said to me at the park you see
what california's governor is doing now
and this is what i said to you for the
last four years
in california i don't know what it is
i felt like i've been in a reality show
i really have
the last year and a half of me living in
california i think i was on a reality
show
with what was coming out of people's
mouths what people were starting to say
what people were thinking it was and
this includes everybody
i mean a lot of people would drive me
crazy in california i don't know
where you know this [__]
non-participation
this participation trophy that [__]
started biting us in the ass in that way
like four years ago because people were
expecting stuff
for free like they've never done nothing
but
all that [__] aside that doesn't bother
me what got me going
was the political side of things you
know july 12th no school for a year
listen we got to say no school until
further notice
we're trying to take care of the problem
not just shut down the school for a year
personally i don't know what government
newsom personally i don't know
mayor garcetti i don't know anybody i i
really don't
i know a guy that worked for garcetti as
an assistant whatever
but i don't know anybody up there
you know i i don't have much knowledge
on politics and whatnot i tell you
the little secrets i have but i don't
have much
i don't know anything i don't know
anything about nancy pelosi
i know that now people are opening up
[__] barbers because
ever since nancy pelosi got a head down
with no mask on
people said [__] you i'm doing what i
need to do with no [__] mascot so
i do know all that shit's going on but
the other day
newsom i guess said something i did not
read it i did not hear it
thank god like i said i'm trying to keep
my mind clear
and trying to stay a little [__] uh
happy
i just want to be happy so
somebody came up to me at the park and
like did you see what [__] newsroom
is doing now
[__] thanksgiving now i didn't say
this i'm not saying this to you guys
this is somebody told me
and then i asked a friend of mine he's
like yeah he made that [__] quote
thanksgiving two families could come
over
for two hours just two families so it's
your family of three
or four and another family to come over
he wants you to hopefully get them
tested
but for two hours only for thanksgiving
no singing laughing yelling
is allowed you know this is the kind of
[__] that you sit there and go what
this is communism two hours two parties
you know two families no singing yelling
no halloween that's communism you know
listen give everybody a choice give
everybody a [__] choice here in new
jersey
there's kids that go to mercy school
that their parents aren't letting them
go to school
i respect that decision for me you know
i don't have
if mercy had two brothers and sisters
i don't know how i feel maybe i feel
differently maybe i just homeschool them
get somebody to come in and have them
play on a [__] day that brother and
sister
that's what families do but since she
doesn't have a brother or a sister
and i have no brothers and sisters that
have cousins or whatever
it's not like i could just leave her at
home all day
but you know even that [__] like no i
have an option of sending her to school
or i could keep it on me i want to i
want to
continue her social development it's
very very
crucial to them at this age that their
social development you know what
it's crucial to them at every age you
ever go to a day care and you go with
your daycare where your kid is five and
he's in there with three and the kids
are the three are advanced
because they're around more kids all the
time they're around more kids they're
they see it they they learn from [__]
watching they imitate
but i got a solo child i can't you know
i'm 57 there's nothing about me that
spells kiddo
except that i get goofy once in a while
there's nothing about i mean i feel bad
for her because
yeah not to play with the ball and all
that [__] but like she plays board games
and stuff
i don't know i play no [__] board
games she wants to play like uno
i play uno with her and i play like this
game that you have to [__] hit a
board
and the dice comes up and then you have
to move it's sort of like monopoly you
have to get four pegs but all that other
[__]
i i don't know what the [__] is going on
so my decision
was for her for her to come back here
and have a social life
i didn't want her to get stuck and it's
really interesting she still talks to
friends in california
by facetime and i can tell you something
you could hear those kids in their voice
like even though i'm [__] deaf i
could hear him when she's on the in the
room with the kids
and sometimes i go to the bathroom or i
gotta go back to get a shirt or
something like that
and i can hear how out of control these
kids are these kids were all great kids
but for the last six three or four
months there's been no
consistency in their lives if my
daughter was home right now in
california we would be home all [__]
day
on the zoom and on saturday we might
have a [__] play date
that's gonna set her back years
so that was it that was [__] it and i
wanted to be happier i just didn't see
myself
being that much happier in l.a you know
i was stuck
i was in a rut you know my comedy was
everything i thought was in a rut so now
i'm out of the rut i'm out of the
[__] quicksand
and i'm on to the last chapter of my
[__] life i mean i'm 57 what do i
expect to do
travel till i'm [__] mick jagger i
hope
knock on wood for all of us that i'm
around and i can still sling some
[__] dick while i'm 75
but let's see what happens for now we're
doing [__] vinnies
we got the podcast we got social media
you're trying to put the pieces together
so am i so we can relate to each other
so let's start with that that's uncle
joey's joint for the week
that's it for wednesday october 21st
i want you to [__] check out our
sponsors whether it's
manscape whether it's movement watches
whether it's cbd lion and that's it and
that's that
we'll be back next monday morning ready
to rip your [__] hearts out
and who knows what we'll add by then but
we always got something for you
have a great week i love you
[__] with all my heart
and thank you very much for supporting
me on youtube patreon
twitter facebook whatever you do and
the merch is coming but you got to give
me a breathe all right [__]
stay black love you guys now
for a word from our sponsors
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
manscape listen balls are kept
you got to keep them [__] nice and
sharp okay women go down there around
the [__] dick area makes your dick
look bigger
manscaped has been there for you since
day one they advertise on tv
they're at the ufc this is why i love
these [__] guys
and their product is number one they
keep you sharp if it wasn't for manscape
we'd have a [__] forest down there
between our [__] legs
now listen how they gonna tell your
balls are [__] magnificant
if it looks like the [__] wolf man if
you want beautiful women to fall all
over themselves for your [__] nut
sack
you gotta go to manscape but now they
got the entire system
to keep your entire body looking as good
as [__] you understand me
as good as your ball sack you ready for
this they got the performance package
it comes with the weed whacking those
hair trimmer now
you start with the nose hairs you know
god knows what you smell let's say you
smell of an [__]
it goes into your mind you process it
and it goes away
but the residue from that dust sits in
your [__] nose head you don't need
that
that's why you gotta manscape the
[__] nose
with the performance package you get
that head trimmer now you can get right
up there with 9000 rpm motor
that's like a [__] puerto ricans mini
bike you understand me
and a blade that moves 360 degrees
the weed whacker has the same skin safe
technology as the razor
so you don't want accidentally suck your
[__] brain out
you also get the lawnmower 3.0 the best
trimmer known to mankind
tremendous on the nut sack and you get
the crop preservative
which tightens up your nutsack and the
reviver
to keep everything smelling [__]
magnifique
plus they're throwing in the free travel
bag and if you order right now
you get the [__] bag and listen it's
got a little zipper inside on the left
and it's black
when you travel you can put a couple
things in there if you know what i'm
talking about that's why i love the
travel bag
get your face as good as your balls
looking as good as your balls
with the performance package trust me i
hit this [__] package all the time
they're about to send me the [__] uh
because that in the move i lost the
[__] weed whacker from my nose
so now i got [__] growing in my nose i
haven't seen before but all that aside
get 20 off the entire package and free
shipping
at manscape.com joey that's 20
off with free shipping at mansafe.com
keep your balls [__] nice
the joint is also brought to you by the
movement
movement watches are all about looking
good while keeping it simple
they don't tell you how many steps
you've taken or beep every time your
lady texts
like a true gentleman it just tells you
the [__] time that's it
movement was started by two college
dropouts so they know what it's like to
have a tight budget that's why
they started movement to bring quality
products
to the masses that's why movement
watches just started 95
you're looking at paying four dollars
for the same quality from a traditional
brand forget that nonsense go
to movement right now you get 15
off with free shipping and free returns
by going to mbmt.com
again that's
slash mvmt.com mvnt is launching new
styles on their site all the time
plus the sunglasses they have are
tremendous i'm waiting for a shipment
of the dust sunglasses in black and the
element international waters
with the gunmetal grave band is going to
[__] knock you out when i get them i
should be getting them to there tomorrow
so do me a favor go to mbmt.com joey
and join the movement the joint is also
brought to you by
cbd lion listen to me
go to cbdlion.com look at that
third-party lab results
read about cbd cbn and all the
advantages it has to you
nobody on the corner store is gonna have
this type of knowledge
it's all in front of your fingertips i
know you got the internet
so go to cbdlion.com from the gummies
the bath ball the tincture the roll
on the cbd cream you can rub right and
it sinks right into your skin i use it
as a moisturizer
you got cbd line infused kinesiology
tape
cd cbd line has you covered from a to
[__] b
the rest is up to you all right i want
to thank cbd lion so go to cbdlion.com
right now
preston joey and get 10 percent off sent
right to your [__] house all right no
drama
no nonsense no [__] that's
cbdlion.com
joey now do me a favor i want to thank
cbd lion i want to thank movement
watches mb
mt and i also want to thank mansgate
for sponsoring us today i want i want to
thank you cox suckers for listening to
the show
for supporting on patreon and for doing
what you do
have a great [__] weekend stay black
and [__] don't go to no covidium
situations all right
there you go one shot louie i love your
[Music]
cocktails
do
[Music]
you